madame monsieur bonsoir et bienvenue sur
fr3 vous vous rappelez certainement il
ya une quinzaine de jours à notre dame
de gravenchon un marocain était agressé
hier soir à l'initiative des syndicats
et des partis de gauche des verts aussi
les écologistes un collectif sos racisme
a été créé un autre dame de gravenchon
thierry paquot la violence émigré à
l'étranger année manifestations
violentes batailles ans ici même à notre
dame de gravenchon le 13 février dernier
quatre jeunes lycéens laissé pour mort
sur le trottoir un immigré marocain de
45 ans une agression raciste à l'état
pur quelques centaines de personnes ont
fêté hier soir l'effort de la condamner
publiquement comme d'ailleurs toutes les
autres formes de racisme qui peuvent
s'exprimer
un rassemblement qui était aussi
l'occasion de créer un collectif sos
racisme une association pas comme les
autres qui ne repose que sur
l'engagement antiraciste individuel le
racisme il a toujours été présent ce qui
se passe en ce moment c'est que nous on
est persuadé qu'en france il ya moins il
ya beaucoup moins de raciste raid anti
raciste le problème c'est que dans la
conjoncture actuelle c'est les racistes
qui parlent haut et fort et nous ça ne
peut pas l'admettre heures à combattre
s'il ya plus de 10 % d'immigrés à notre
dame de gravenchon curieusement ils
n'étaient pas très nombreux à participer
hier soir à ce rassemblement tels s'il
ne se sentait pas vraiment concerné pire
parce qu'il considère peut-être le
racisme comme une fatalité
une opinion qui n'est en tout cas pas
partagée par ceux qui avaient décidé de
s'afficher sans aucune agressivité
antiraciste de s'afficher et de
combattre toute forme de supériorité
ration certain nombre de collègues
constate par exemple que dans des
classes de 4e de troisième ou de l'aide
il ya quelques années quand on traitait
du racisme en classe disons que les les
racistes entre guillemets ou potentiels
se taisait aujourd'hui vous avez sur une
classe un quart à un tiers qui nous qui
dit ouvertement ce qu'elle pense du
racisme et qui développent des propos
racistes croix avec une certaine
outrecuidance avec beaucoup moins de
réserves qu'avant on peut dire qu'on
fait que le boulot a fait marche arrière
ou ce qu'est ce qui peut dire
précisément ce qui peut dire je crois
qu'il faut expliquer l'essentiel c'est
de comprendre que on apprend par la
différence ça je crois que c'est
fondamental on n'explique pas un gamin
que c'est bien ou que c'est mal parce
que il faut pas le faire on lui explique
grosso modo que les cultures les autres
cultures
les autres comportements les autres
tenues des gens nous apprennent des
choses et qu'on sent enrichi wavre le 7
mars prochain sera organisée une journée
nationale contre le racisme